I'm gonna jump right into it because I'm
so excited for the new season of the
bull SEC you guys are coming back pretty
soon yeah what can you say about that
first episode back where do you think
speak up well for my character Kat her
hot has just been ripped out of her
chest and I think like a lot of people
know what that feels like so she's kind
of trying to rebuild some
self-confidence and find herself again
and there's also a little like guest
star from Betty who who's whose album
just came out a lot Betty who by the way
friendship between the three girls what
what's going on this season well you
know I think it's gonna be fun to see
them grow up you know we've seen through
season one and two they've kind of
changed a little bit and again in season
three but oh no they're always gonna be
each other's people you know
last season we really saw like boss lady
cat come out in a way where does that
storyline go and this come and season uh
well we're gonna see cat maybe get
involved in some quality stuff he's
running for office if she's gonna be
involved I'm not allowed to say any more
than that and I almost did I've known as
the person who gets spoilers so I'm not
gonna do it but yes politicking stuff
Liv and I might be so wrong but I almost
feel like parallel between cat and a OC
who everyone isn't you know what that's
that's who I tried to channel because
why we were shooting that AMC was really
coming up and I loved her so much
have you bet her no I just like stalk
her I mean I feel like we all do yeah so
we get some political cats that's what
you're telling me how is single cat
single cat is single as a Pringle you
know no well there might be another love
on the horizon somebody new somebody new
somebody new somebody who I love a lot
yeah character wears companies every day
yeah a new character and I think that
all right hope I think people are gonna
really like it but also like Adina is
coming back because she's that ex that
never goes away you know people really
do love Edina and cat together like we
root for them in a way any hope of a
reconciliation well I hope so
I love cat Medina I'm like I'm the one
that cried when they get broken up like
just reading the script because I'm a
fan what happened I can't wait
give me three words to describe season 3
season 3 Oh naked messy naked and messy
[Music]
you